Fox News Alert thousands of illegal
immigrants flooding over our Southern
border each and every day now a caravan
of at least 6,000 is closing in both
sides of the aisle pressuring President
Biden to do something to stop it and do
it now this is the faor focus hello
everyone I'm Julie Banderas in for
Harris today so Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin and Homeland Security
secretary Alejandra mayorcas were both
in Mexico yesterday to discuss the
Border crisis DHS calls their meeting
with the president president oor in
Mexico and others quote very productive
Republican Congresswoman Nancy ma says
it's not even close to good
enough blink's visit to Mexico is all
about paying lip service to this issue
we are seeing Independence Republicans
and Democrats getting very angry about
what they're seeing at the border this
is a massive massive problem for the
Biden Administration they refuse to
address
it self-proclaimed Sanctuary cities are
crumbling under the massive weight we of
the crisis Texas sending busloads and
now Planes full of illegals their way a
tiny fraction of what border communities
are facing right now Democratic Mayors
meantime from New York Denver and
Chicago are tearing into Texas governor
Greg Abbot listen but this is a national
problem that has only been exagerated by
Governor Abbott's cruel inhumane
politics Denver finds itself right now
at Ground Zero in trying to resolve and
respond to the migrant crisis we are the
first big city north of El Paso and the
cheapest bus ticket and the shortest
trip for uh the governor and all local
economies are not designed and built to
respond to this type of Crisis we are
literally building a system as we go
along team Fox coverage Nate Foy on
those liberal City Mayors now feeling
the heat first Fox businesses gry
Trimble on the Biden administration's
handling
or not handling of the crisis Grady hey
Julie yeah we saw that post on X from
Homeland Security secretary Alejandra
mycus calling yesterday's meeting in
Mexico City very productive but we
didn't really get any specifics from
mayorcas or Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin who was also in the room
Mexico's president oor this morning
though said the two sides agreed to open
rail crossings at the border that had
been closed because of the surge of
migrants but he says fentel
hardly came
up unfortunately I think this is just a
hey we went down there they'll check the
box but nothing's going to get resolved
they went down there for a photo op but
the policies have not changed if they
were serious about it they would look at
the tools that they took off the table
such as the remain in Mexico policy
notably while the meeting was taking
place and still right now A group of
thousands of migrants is making its way
through Mexico toward the United States
and it's not clear how either country
plans to deal with that Caravan just
this month there have been more than
250,000 migrant encounters at the
southern border more than
35,000 encounters over Christmas weekend
alone in meantime immigration talks in
the Senate are ongoing but slow goinging
they're happening remotely this week
with so many lawmakers taking time off
for the holidays Julie grd Trimble thank
you very much so three of those
Sanctuary City Mayors held a virtual
media brief yesterday they are demanding
restrictions on when and how many of
Governor Abbott's buses can arrive and
they're pleading with the federal
government for more funding National
border patrol council president Brandon
Jud says all the blame should go to
Biden if they would actually come from a
position of strength and and start
talking to Biden like it's his fault
then they would get his attention these
Mayors need to Clearly say this problem
is is a federal government problem it's
not a Greg Abbott problem it's a federal
government problem and if they put the
blame where where it lies then they have
a chance of getting this crisis fixed
Nate Foy with more hey Nate hey Julie so
moving forward charter bus companies
will have to communicate with New York
City 32 hours before dropping migrants
off at a designated location this is
after an executive order from mayor
Adams all drop offs must happen between
8:30 amm and noon Monday through Friday
now any Buzz company that fails to do
that could be fined or face other
penalties mayor Adams issued the
executive order Wednesday after a record
14 migrant buses arrived from Texas in a
single day last week Adam said he can't
even get a meeting with President Joe
Biden to address this issue listen to
him
here we cannot continue to do the
federal government's
job we have spoken to FEMA and other
Federal officials who have expressed
concern about the bord surge but not
offer it additional help we need action
and we need it now Julie you mentioned
it the mayors of Chicago and Denver are
also asking for more Federal help they
want more money they also want to
expedite the approval of work
authorizations for migrants Brandon Jud
with the national border patrol Council
says the problem will continue so long
as migrants are incentivized to come
here
illegally if we secure our border we
have to stop releasing these people into
the United States we have to stop giving
that magnet that draws so many people to
cross our borders illegally as long as
we continue to give them Aid they're
going to continue to come Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin and Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro maoris you
saw met with the Mexican president
yesterday discussing the crisis which so
far has seen record-breaking numbers for
illegal migration Grady just mentioned
it the southern border is on Pace for
the most migrant encounters ever in a
single month with roughly 250,000 so far
in December which means more buses could
be coming up to Sanctuary cities like
New York we send it back to you Julie
unbelievable Nate Foy thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-host Harris vulner and Kaylee mcki
on outnumbered every weekday at 12:00
p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights